today's classic interview is one that
many people in our audience just don't
know exists I get a lot of emails from
our audience saying David please
interview Matt Dillahunty and we have
interviewed Matt Dillahunty and that's
the interview we're going to look at
today Matt Dillahunty known as a debater
of religion taking the non-religious
perspective debunking lots of so-called
sacred texts and there are many people
in our audience who just don't know that
we've interviewed Matt Dillahunty
because they are relatively new
followers of the show so we will go to
my interview from February of 2014 with
Matt Dillahunty doesn't mean we won't
have him back on but this is a really
really interesting interview to check
out it talks to us about how he went
from almost being a Christian minister
to being a debunker of so-called sacred
texts let's check it out I'm joined
today by Matt Dillahunty he is host of
the Atheist Experience he's regularly
engaging in formal debates travels the
u.s. speaking to local secular
organizations and university groups as
part of the secular Student Alliance as
speakers bureau a bunch of our audience
actually suggested that we have Matt on
and interestingly enough Matt it it a
lot of those recommendations were after
I had a conversation with a pastor named
Carl Gallup's
and I had asked Carl to give me some
kind of evidence a reason why he
believes the Bible is the Word of God
that comes from outside the Bible itself
and we basically got to the point where
he was number one talking about
Deuteronomy as evidence from outside the
Bible
that the Bible is the Word of God but
then he also said that the fact that
things that the Bible predicts have
happened would be evidence that the
Bible is a Word of God so most of my
audience that's an argument that didn't
make sense I'm curious how you tackle
those arguments in the debates that you
do I think I would have done you know
very much the same thing you did I keep
asking for evidence from outside the
Bible so that we're not in this position
of constantly trying to verify because
the Bible's just claims it can't also be
the evidence for the claim
so I think I'd taken a similar task or
attacked on that but it's strange that
this is what keeps coming up I did a
debate last Friday with Ray Comfort
although I wouldn't call it a debate
where he just said flatly he had no
interest in demonstrating God existed we
already know were just lying about it
and he believes the Bible and that's all
there is to it so it's a very difficult
subject to get through because they're
beginning with a very different starting
point than we are about how you
determine what's reasonable to believe
when you were thinking of being a
Baptist minister for some time was there
a specific moment you remember where you
said not only am I not sure I want to be
a Baptist minister I don't think I
believe in Christianity anymore yeah
there was a I can't pinpoint a single
moment or a single event or even a
single argument I was basically studying
with the goal of eventually convincing
my atheist roommate although we had had
no conversations about this and this was
a fairly long period of study I was
between jobs as I am today
and over about 18 months or so it was
let me be the best defender of
Christianity I can be let me fulfill my
obligation under first Peter 3:15 to
give the reason for the faith that's
within me and at some point and I don't
remember exactly when or why it was just
like the the wealth of information just
kind of pushed my belief to collapse to
where I said you know I don't know what
I believe I don't know if I believe in a
God but I definitely don't believe what
I used to believe so let me investigate
further let me see if there's some other
God or some other God concept within
Christian or outside of it that could be
true or that I that I think is more
reasonable and that led to kind of a
deeper study of philosophy and logic and
skepticism to determine you know how to
direct that search so when that happened
was your initial feeling one of
disappointment or or being kind of an it
was it a negative emotional state or was
it in a way positive and liberating
because I could see it going either way
yeah and I have seen it go either way I
get tons of email from people who
are you know elated as I was you know by
the time I finally realized that I could
should identify as an atheist
it was incredibly liberating it was you
know it's not somebody I didn't dwell in
the fact that I had believed something
that I now thought was incorrect for so
many years I embraced the fact that now
I've been corrected it's it's kind of
the the foundation of science and and
similar thinking that you want to
believe as many true things and a few
false things as possible and so when
you're corrected that's a wonderful
thing because now you've got reality but
I've heard from so many people who were
just despondent and quite many of them
were upset over this idea that they had
lost an eternal life and that always
struck me as strange because I don't
couldn't see how you could lose
something that you never had that's
interesting and this idea of being open
to the changing of beliefs kind of came
up in this debate between Bill Nye and
Ken Ham from the creation is a museum I
have a couple of specific questions
about the debate for you but what were
your thoughts about the debate happening
in general it was very interesting to me
but my concern was that in some way it
was legitimizing the views of Ken Ham as
worthy of being debated in this very
kind of elaborate way with a scientist
and that that in and of itself was it
was a concern yeah that's a common
objection that people like Richard
Dawkins and others if it's the reason
why Richard doesn't debate creationist I
wasn't so much concerned for that reason
I was opposed to it in general because
my understanding is that the Creation
Museum was in financial trouble and to
me this was Bill Nye taking the
opportunity to make sure that they got a
bunch of money because no matter how
this debate turned out Ken Ham is going
to make money off this if you if he
would have done well in one which I
don't think is the case or even
portrayed it really well he that's a
marketing tool and if he fails as
evidently even Christian website polls
show that 92 percent thought bill bill
nye one that still becomes a marketing
tool for him because he can say look
we've got to do more we need more money
to debate this and do you know bring
more information and we've got to do a
better job all of this just kind of
funds the
Museum now overall I thought Bill did a
good job I mean there were mistakes but
Ken Ham was I'm sorry to say such a poor
debater that he just kind of missed them
one of the most interesting things
specifically from the debate was this
moment where they were each asked what
might change their minds and Ken Ham
essentially said nothing that it doesn't
matter what could what anybody could
tell him or show him he's going to
believe that the Bible is the little
literal word of God whereas Bill Nye
said well evidence would change my mind
and when people talk to me about this I
say I have no personal interest in there
not being a god I have no personal
interest in making those who believe
that feel bad or proving them wrong I
have an interest in just believing what
I think is the truth truth based on
evidence that has been presented to me
I'm 100% open to the idea that there is
a higher power of some kind it could be
a god it could be a more advanced
civilization that has created the
universe as a simulation as I've talked
to astro physicist Lawrence Krauss about
do you find that most non-believers are
in the camp of being open to their being
a God or they're in the camp of knowing
there is no God it's really hard to say
because I primarily you know run in
circles of skeptics and in this of those
atheists that are skeptics and that are
atheist because of skeptical reasons I
think that they're all open there were
hey should give us the evidence show us
you know we would like to believe as
many true things as few false things as
possible we're not beginning with this
we don't want to believe in a god thing
there are plenty of atheists out there
who just flatly assert no there's no
such thing as God and I have no interest
in you know that even possibly being
true and there are others who say things
similar that are often misrepresented
you know Hitchens famously said that you
know this idea of the Christian God in
particular he wouldn't even want it to
be true and what he was what he meant I
definitely agree with you know he was
talking about the character of this
individual in the model that they've
created in the universe for him but if
there is God I'd certainly like to know
about it I'm not in any way proposing
that it's necessarily impossible that
there's nothing that qualifies in that
realm it's just that I haven't seen the
evidence for it one of the things that
kind of bothers me sometimes when I hear
from people about kind of questioning my
my beliefs is the idea that what what if
I'm wrong type of thing and again it's
it's not one of these things where I'm
an econ any kind of crusade I I was
raised Jewish relatively secular I had a
couple years of Hebrew school it was
never understood within my family that
what I'm being taught is literally true
but the idea was there's kind of
interesting cultural stuff here about
Jews as a people that we kind of want
you to grow up in and it was never
adversarial for me in any way and I find
that that's sometimes something that
comes up very often talking to those who
are very religious that it seems it has
always been an adversarial thing for
them this does God exist or does God not
exist where for me it was hey I'm open
to it either way yeah it's not I don't
like you know I'd love to find out
whether or not this is actually true
there's the various claims that a God
exists I find that you know coming from
your background of primarily cultural
Judaism that yeah the conflict is not as
prevalent there in part cuz you have to
do so much work to become a Jew of you
if you weren't born one and the you know
Reform Judaism doesn't even require that
one actually believe in a God but coming
from my background there certainly is a
lot more adversarial mm-hmm
to this but my biggest I'm most
definitely an evangelical atheist or a
preaching atheist and actually I'm I'm
probably preaching on behalf of
skepticism but unlike some skeptics who
would say that they don't care what
people would believe they care about the
methods that they use to reach those
please
I actually also care about what people
believe because what people believe
informs their actions and their actions
have consequences for themselves and
others so I care that somebody you know
believes that their God has ordained for
example marriage as being one man one
woman forever the effects of that are
very real for people yeah it's the
actions they take on behalf of the
beliefs and it seems to me kind of
non-productive counterproductive to say
I don't care about your beliefs I only
care about your actions if you really
care about the actions you work to
educate people so that their beliefs
change we've been speaking with Matt
Dillahunty he is
host of the atheist experience check
that out Matt great to have you on and
I'm sure we had plenty of time for more
and we'll definitely have you back
thanks very much David I appreciate it